moi mon but c'est de rendre irréversible
ce virage de la prévention euh pas
simplement l'illustrant par les éléments
qui sont dans le texte la vaccination
contre les infections liées au papillom
virirus pris en charge à 100 % ou la
gratuité des préservatifs pour les moins
de de 26 ans euh ou encore la prise en
charge des protections menstruelles
réutilisaes pour les moins de 26 ans et
les plus précaires euh ou des
dispositifs sur l'activité physique
adaptée euh je pense il y a des éléments
sur la prévention qui sont encore plus
structurants et notamment que de plus en
plus prévention et innovation ça va
vouloir dire la même chose en matière
mais il y a des des médecins qui sont
beaucoup plus sachants que moi autour de
la table de médecine prédictive de
personnalisation de la médecine il y a
qu'àavir aujourd'hui sur le repérage et
le traitement anticipé du cancer des
choses absolument exceptionnelles qui
sont qui sont en train de se passer sous
nos yeux et qui vont être qui vont
changer la donne